it's a great question right why aren't
activist investors going after a stock
like McDonald's why don't you think they
have well I think that's still on the
plate of potential there uh I mean
McDonald's has a great Global brand uh
it has a good balance sheet so those are
very attractive uh elements for an
activist investor to go after and it
doesn't take a you know a lot of shares
to really acquire and get some uh some
motivation into it uh you'll have the
institutional investors backing you yes
uh to create shareholder value uh I
agree with that Chris I mean you might
even only need a bill akman to say
something and and and to get something
going on uh the stock moving and
investors uh talking about it so uh in
McDonald's case Chris uh what would a
scenario be if an activist investor got
into this company what would you want to
see them change at
McDonald's well I think it's essentially
is the menu uh that is what is going to
attract customers restaurants have to
win on same store sales and they have to
see the traffic they have to see the
average check now McDonald's average
check has been going up a little bit but
their traffic has been coming off fairly
strong so you're going to have to have
something that's going to attract them
uh we look at some of the winning
categories like Chipotle which was a
McDonald's own company until 2006 right
and even Panera Bread they've had a
whole host of great traffic great
numbers great growth uh and that's what
you know is driving some of it it's this
current uh fast fresh uh approach that
is being very attractive to the
Millennials Generation X and that is
where McDonald's needs you know to take
some of their action towards well but
that would mean completely changing the
business model though uh wouldn't it
Chris of McDonald's I mean Chipotle
Panera yes they've grown by the way
they're smaller than McDonald's uh but
they're fast casual I mean we're talking
here fast food and McDonald's wins not
just on the food but on how fast they
get it to their
customers right speed is is very
important uh McDonald's has probably one
of the strongest drive-through traffic
in the business so H getting that to
them is there they have tried with
different aspects the um mcafe to try
and uh combat against Starbucks uh
smoothies to also heighten the uh the
natural aspects and even salads so they
do have some of those aspects out there
but there's still a very question on the
food quality uh We've even seen some of
the recent uh you know researches saying
that is where people are questioning uh
the value of of the purchase and um you
know this is couple of the strategies
their last quarter numbers came out at
uh weaker than expected blaming a lot on
foreign tax impact uh but really uh
Thompson's strategy was really to uh
enhance the menu and enhance the digital
strategy right and and to his you know
to his credit he has been trying to
change up the menu and he has been
trying to add more technology and use
social media so he's trying different
things right now but still it still begs
the question who might come in and while
this is all speculative right now Chris
uh you know who do you think uh could be
a possible active investor in
McDonald's oh I I think it could be a
whole host of you know hedge funds out
there that want to capture shareholder
value and they might come in with
bringing in you know new board members
or even trying strategies of some
Financial engineering to see more uh
stock BuyBacks dividend growth um or
even you know changing some of the mix
of uh trans uh transferring more into a
franchise uh uh mentality rather than a
company-owned mentality uh especially in
the outside US markets really capturing
partner
uh Within These markets is definitely a
more valued resource uh than the company
trying to own them all right Chris thank
you so much for joining us on McDonald's
we'll see what happens Chris rowane the
portfolio manager at ball and Gainer the
McDonald's shareholder